[Music]
[Music]
in India you have 700,000 villages and
each village has at least two or three
bends there is no marriage without a man
there is no death without Caban
there is no butter fill out the band and
bands they need instruments roughly 90%
of india's brass band instruments come
from this musical alley jolly Cote Lane
in the city of Meerut very Cody Lane has
about 100 manufactures but one of the
most renowned is nadir alley company mr.
naturally was my uncle started this
company in 1885 he was the first man who
started a band in India here is the
first man in 1900 with 24 people it was
immensely liked by the Indian people and
his uncle wasn't the only one with a
passion for the family business my
father's father my father myself and all
my children so you can say the fourth
generation is here we make brass band
musical instruments like trumpets
coordinates a phone IAM cuba and also
percussion instruments like drums and
things like that you see in instrument
making is an art our instruments are the
best because we use a system of quality
control the most important thing in
making instrument is the composition of
brass the material quality the
instruments from here go to many
countries anywhere from Saudi Arabia to
Germany to France I have devoted my life
and making instruments music is the
elixir of life when you play and you you
concentrate and you play a good fuel or
hear a good tune you think you are out
of this world music is something but you
listen to it and you're lost and you're
happy
[Music]
remember back together every time I give
you a 3/4 breathe on for an attack on
one I put so much love and effort sweat
blood and tears into this band program
[Music]
we are the best marching band in the
country my name is Abraham Duffy jr. and
I am the head your major for the sonic
boom of the south we bring something
that no other band brings excitement
jaw-dropping in-your-face entertainment
the justice a drum majors are at the
heart of the band we are known for our
showmanship but what a lot of people
don't know is we teach music to the band
we lead the band we help with formations
and we also help guide the band and the
beginning of August we practice for
about 20 hours a day from 5:00 a.m. to
12 a.m. in the morning you really just
have to find time to sleep not only is
it physical training is also mental and
emotional training as well
there's needed in order to be a part of
a program of our caliber what goes on is
a lot of plane a lot of plane and a lot
of plane and also marching marching
marching marching marching
[Music]
being a physical shape gives you
endurance it helps you play better and
perform better and also gives you muscle
memory
[Music]
this is my fourth and final year as John
Major my hope for the future of the ban
is to just exhale be better than the
Bands before them be better musicians
just to finally be at the end it's
bittersweet but I am going to lead and
never look back because I know I made my
mark
[Music]
[Applause]
we break necks all the title
it's kind of like the deer in the
headlights look when they see us because
it's unexpected
[Music]
a bunch of brown Indian boys walking
down Fifth Avenue in New York City and
killed since you don't see that every
day
[Music]
my name is Tushar Patel I'm the bagpipe
player and pipe major for shreem Oakland
even started up a pipe band located at
Shri Rama and temple and Secaucus New
Jersey
this Roman religion is a more modern
religion it's a sect of Hinduism that
promotes unity non-violence and peace
and well-being all throughout the world
music is definitely the fundamental of
our faith our spiritual leader Shri
Mataji when starting up a loved music he
fell in love with the sound of the
bagpipes so he instructed us to start
our own bagpipe band
[Music]
no one had any idea how to play bagpipe
music
[Music]
we found online videos internet videos
we bought a bunch of intro to bagpipe
books we didn't know any music but we
knew that if we work together if we were
unified that we can do anything the
sound of the bagpipes it's very similar
to some instruments that are found in
India while we're playing a Scottish
bagpipe we're still playing Indian music
as well as American music and music from
all around the world
being here in America we really wanted
to blend all the cultures that our band
represents we like to maintain that
traditional Scottish uniform but we also
like to blend in the Indian and American
culture that uniqueness is what defines
our band there's really a sense of pride
we're proud of each other and proud of
where we've grown it's not about only
just playing the bagpipes the reason
that we play is to continue spreading
our message of peace and unity through
music
[Music]
we're not different than anybody else
we're the consider us I have mental
handicaps in Finland there's a punk band
that marches to the beat of its own riot
where we get along better decor economy
pivot has been around as a band for over
eight years and in 2016
these rock stars decided this will be
their last year performing together this
is their story
some riders bass drums and the bass
player were from Helsinki Finland we
started play pop rock the physical space
but one of the punk rock band
yes cos we would like to start to prove
performing of a punk band okay of the
rest is history like you saying we love
punk music because of our facts with a
rock on and haven't it time it's also
really personal so it's hard to talk
about that the listen to the songs and
let the music tell the story
it's there just like a workplace now
everything is fine when we are on the
stage they're having a good time we're
having a good time for their or not
having a good time we don't have a good
time
we're four middle-aged guys who laughs -
rock and roll
we need whiskey whiskey yeah
we have cutaway I love a good cigars
sometimes yeah people just cause he has
to be playing we won't walk a lot of the
years music and he just wanted to do
something else that was that that was
the whole idea and we respect that
so 26th of December is our last gig for
it ever
and then this pipe is history we're
little sad about it but what like this
is life
[Music]